the shift has been completed from there
was no collusion to collusion wouldn't
be illegal to everybody colludes this is
no big deal and a really good question
now is would the collusion be against
the law or not and the answer is well
you actually have to dig into the
details collusion is sort of like a
catch-all for many possible crimes as
well as some non criminal activities so
we can't even really say would collusion
be legal or illegal it really matters
specifically what laws were looking at
what laws might have been broken it's a
pretty damn long list of them related to
the Trump jr. Trump Tower meeting with
that Russian lawyer ostensibly to get
dirt on Hillary Clinton we have the
prohibition on contributions donations
expenditures independent expenditures
and disbursements by foreign Naturals
that's 52 foreign nationals that's 52
u.s. code 31 21 and 36 u.s. code 510 and
if you merely solicit something of value
from a foreign national regardless of
whether you get it that may be a
violation of the law and as we know it's
in writing that meeting was for the
purposes of getting promised information
about Hillary Clinton from a foreign
power it doesn't matter whether Donald
Trump jr. got the information or not
there's possible conspiracy charges as
well conspiracy per se is 18 USC 371 and
there's the possible conspiracy to
violate several potentially applicable
laws that includes 18 USC 1030 fraud and
related activity in connection with
computers there's 18 USC 1343 wire fraud
and there's also 52 USC 3121 which is
again contributions and donations by
foreign nationals what about aiding and
abetting aiding and abetting is on the
table as a possible crime committed by
Trump or Associates that's 18 us code
two we also have talked briefly before
about the Logan Act the Logan Act may of
have been violated and that would lead
to potential fine or imprisonment of
unauthorized citizens who negotiate with
foreign governments having a dispute
with the United States Russia would
count there and that would apply to the
discussions that Michael Flynn had with
Russian individuals about sanctions that
as we're increasingly learning might
even include Jeff Sessions discussions
with Sergei kis Lee at the Russian
ambassador so there's that there's also
been espionage floated I believe that
the most likely way that would apply
would be the recommendation to the
Russians
to hack or try to influence the election
so we could be talking about potential
espionage and then there's of course in
the back pocket pat treason although it
is very difficult to prove there is 18
USC 2381
which states that whoever owing
allegiance to the United States levies
war against them or adheres to their
enemies giving them aid and comfort
within the United States or elsewhere is
guilty of treason and shall suffer death
or shall be in prison not less than five
years and fined under this title but not
less than $10,000 that also might
require require a declaration of war
against Russia and that's probably not
going to happen no this is this is a
very long list I didn't even get into
bribery right if for example the Dom jr.
meeting resulted in some kind of
agreement like Russia helps Trump win
and in exchange we help you to settle
the Prairies cases that are going on or
we look at the adoption sanctions or
whatever that arguably would be a form
of bribery and it could fall under
federal prosecution of public corruption
in the United States those are certainly
the major crimes and what about you know
maybe perjury there's going to be a lot
of public officials who have to speak to
Congress about this I don't know if Don
Jr and Paul Manafort are ever going to
testify to Congress under oath but maybe
eventually they will be those people are
known liars and if they get caught lying
there could be charges that come out of
as a result of that they may have to
subpoena certain information and
documents to Congress and if they don't
comply then you're talking about
attempt of Congress there so there
definitely are a few other ones yeah and
you're actually talking about the next
layer which is that that in the attempt
to cover up or suppress information
leaking out about the crimes I've just
mentioned to you there could be
subsequent crimes committed like perjury
and of course we have to talk about
obstruction of justice right there are
six federal obstruction laws one of
those is 18 US Code 1512 and objective
obstruction of justice has many
possibilities the firing of James Comey
could be intimidation which is a form of
obstruction the threatening of Sally
Yates before her testimony the
threatening of James Comey about better
hope there are no tapes and demanding
loyalty from Comey in the Oval Office
meeting the alleged requests to the NSA
director about well maybe you could shut
down the Russia investigation these are
all potentially attempt at obstructing
justice and threatening Robert Mulder's
job even right that entire red line
thing if Robert Muller starts
investigating my business dealings and
my family's businesses Trump said he
would see that as sort of a red line
even inviting James Comey to dinner
under false pretenses which were
actually that that meeting was actually
meant to try to get him to either you
know the loyalty pledge or knock off the
Russia investigation all of that could
count Pat as possible obstruction of
justice
is it possible though that we may be
getting a bit ahead of ourselves here
because while the Don jr. stuff was big
and certainly pointed to the fact there
there's some extent of Trump Russia
collusion I mean is it a bit too early
to talk about criminal charges or
impeachment proceedings that's part of
the issue which is we don't actually
know right now what Muller has right and
until we actually figure out what does
Muller have it's going to be very
difficult to even know what possible
criminal charges are on the table but
the bottom line is you've got the right
increasingly saying even if this
happened there would be no crimes to
speak of that's very incorrect right
many laws may have been broken but we
don't yet know what is their actual
evidence of and just because you have
evidence doesn't mean that there will
necessarily be charges or impeachment or
anything else so don't fall for none of
this would be illegal anyway
because collusion per se isn't a crime
collusions a general umbrella term and
there are any number of possible crimes
that have been committed whether we'll
see charges or prosecution is a
different story and under a Republican
House and Senate we may well not discuss
this with us on our reddit discussion
forum at david pakman.com slash our IDI
di t back with part two of my interview
with William Gardner after the break the
video you just watched was made possible
by support from you please go to
patreon.com/scishow you can make a
pledge of as little as one dollar per
month and every dollar helps to support
the work that we're doing particularly
in light of the YouTube ad boycott which
has been really bad